what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we just got the
first full trailer for thor love and
thunder and it did not disappoint we got
our very first look at christian bale as
the villain of thor love and thunder
gore the god butcher and i have to say
he looks pretty dang fantastic i was a
little bit worried at first because we
saw some of the toy leaks of him and he
didn't look okay but this looks
fantastic on screen in fact the whole
entire movie looks like it's going to be
a blast and include quite a bit in it
including the classic thor ragnarok
humor which of course that was directed
by taco attitude and this is as well so
i am expecting kind of the same but on a
bigger scale so let's break down
everything that we saw in this trailer
including an explanation of who gore the
god butcher is and why exactly he is out
there butchering gods so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
future marvel related videos let's get
into it so this trailer opens up with
korg telling a story about thor to a
bunch of people of an alien race now
this could be the entites like i
mentioned in my last trailer breakdown
they're from the comics and they are
blue i don't think they're going to play
a major part in this movie but i do
think that thor and the guardians are
going to be helping them now korg refers
to thor as a space viking which is
obviously very appropriate because
thor's from norse mythology and the
norsemen fighters were vikings now he's
a space viking because he travels
through space opening the bifrost with
stormbreaker which we saw him do in this
trailer and the teaser trailer as well
and he learned how to do this in
avengers infinity war now korg makes
sure to mention that thor was a god he
was no ordinary man he was a god and
that's because gods are gonna play a
huge role in this movie obviously the
main villain is gore the godbutcher we
also see zeus who is supposed to be the
god of gods so the whole theme of gods
is very important not just the thor but
to this entire story of this movie now
from here we get a look at the entire
guardians of the galaxy crew we have
nebula we have drax we have mantis
star-lord of course we even see kraglin
here and we even get a look at groot who
is still somewhat of an older teen not
so much a full adult which makes sense
because the beginning of this movie when
thor's with the guardians is going to
take place right after the events of
avengers end game and an in-game groot
was still a teenager now korg says thor
went on a new journey we can see him
strike stormbreaker into the ground and
his costume changes this appears to be
where he goes from ravanger thor which
is who he is when he's with the
guardians to a new thor thor the god of
thunder who is going to seek out what is
happening to all of the other gods we
have the same scene in this trailer
where korg and thor are looking at an
insanely huge dead beast and this beast
is actually a god falagar the behemoth
and it comes from thor god of thunder
number three from the comics which was
actually gore the god butcher's debut
and this god was actually a friend of
thor's and in the mcu in thor love and
thunder this is how thor is going to
know that gore the godbutcher is hunting
down gods now at first he won't know its
gore he'll know that something or
someone out there is hunting gods and
he's going to have to figure out who
more on that in a bit now from here korg
says that he got in shape he went from
dad bod to god bod and we can see him
working out and one of his workouts
includes pulling the milano against its
force it's flying one way but he is
pulling it the other way and obviously
it works because thor is in the greatest
shape we've ever seen in this trailer
now from here they show us a scene that
we saw in the first teaser trailer where
thor first sees natalie portman's thor
and if you notice there are a lot of
black creatures in the background now
we're not actually sure what these are
at this point in time because they don't
really give us a good look at them it
actually looks like they are
intentionally trying not to show us them
however i think these are minions of
gore gore the god butcher has the all
black necro sword which originally
belongs to null the god of the symbiotes
and while these don't exactly look 100
like symbiotes here i still think
there's something that gore the god
butcher conjured using the all black
necro sword so they look kind of
symbiotic and maybe they'll mention
symbiotes but i don't think that there's
going to be any venom connections in
this film and then he sees mjolnir he
sees it flying through the air he
reaches for it super happy but then it
turns away because
jane foster's the mighty thor is in
control and the monologue that korg is
going through starts to say that he is
the one and only thor but then he says
he spoke too soon and this is to make it
very very very clear in case you haven't
noticed by her wielding mjolnir and the
armor she's wearing jane foster is thor
she is the mighty thor and she is the
mighty thor in the comics as well now of
course in avengers in-game we watched
thor break down about not being with
jane foster anymore he was obviously
going through a hard time and we
actually know that in the beginning of
this film he's going to be trying to
find himself and a part of that is
probably going to be getting over jane
foster so it might be one of those
classic things to where you're just
about to get over somebody and then they
come right back into your life and we
can tell that just by the way he's
talking saying the old ex-girlfriend and
when she says how long's it been like
three four years thor knows the exact
amount of time it's been since they last
saw each other kind of proving that he
really hasn't moved on yet but hey it's
called thor love and thunder and then
from here we meet gore the god butcher
and there's a lot to talk about him but
first please allow me to thank our
sponsors better help for sponsoring
today's video sometimes life gets pretty
hard and sometimes you just want
somebody to talk to that's where better
help comes in in this chaotic world that
we live in sometimes it's pretty easy to
feel overwhelmed or feel some type of
anxiety whether it's work school family
or relationships sometimes you just want
somebody to talk to and it's also really
good to check up on your mental health
well better help is an online resource
that allows you to do just that
connecting with a therapist online from
the comfort of your home they have a
broad range of officially licensed
therapists over 20 000 therapists in
their network which makes it very
convenient to find a therapist that
works for you and you can change
therapists at any time for free i know
it can be a lot easier to receive
therapy from the comfort of your own
environment and it's not just therapy
sessions you can message your therapist
at any time check out some information
that may be useful to you and schedule
your appointments all from the same page
head to betterhelp.com cosmic to answer
a few questions and get paired up with a
therapist within 48 hours you'll also
get 10 off your first month by clicking
the link in the description down below
that's betterhelp
dot help.com slash cosmic
now from here we meet gore the god
butcher and i believe we actually see
him get the all black necro sword for
the first time here in this scene when
he's reaching for the sword and we hear
him say the only ones who gods care
about is themselves then he says so this
is my vow all gods will die now if
you're not too familiar with who gore is
and why he's the god butcher and why
he's so bitter and wants to kill all the
gods don't worry i got you covered
gore's life was full of tragedy he was
born on a no-name planet where his
entire life he was told to worship the
gods his life wasn't always bad he had a
wife and he had a bunch of kids but
sadly they all started to die and right
before his last son died he prayed and
he begged the gods to help him to save
his son but then his son died after this
he started to express in his city that
he didn't believe that the gods were
real well this led to him getting exiled
by his people however one day while
wandering in the desert waiting to die
he ended up seeing two gods fighting and
falling down to the ground one was a
purple skinned god wearing golden armor
and the other was null the symbiote god
gore in disbelief that the gods were
real went up to the gods in which the
purple skin god begged gore for help
however at that time nol's sword turned
into an amorphous mass and it bonded
with gore and he creates the all-black
necrosword and then he kills the god and
i think that's the scene that we could
be seeing here where gore reaches for
the sword while it's on the beach
obviously the movies don't really follow
the comics shot by shot so i'm assuming
they'll switch up things just a tiny bit
so perhaps he picks up the sword and
then he kills the god and then he leaves
but this is why he swears vengeance on
all other gods gore was at first shocked
that the gods did exist but then he gets
pissed because now he knows that the
gods are real but none of them came to
his aid none of them helped and this is
why in the trailer we hear him say gods
only care about themselves and from
there on in the comics after he gets the
all-black necro sword and kills the
golden armored god he sets out to kill
all the gods and for the most part it
seems like that story is going to remain
pretty similar to the comics and might i
just add gore looks fantastic they
really did an amazing job with christian
bell he looks menacing and terrifying
now from here we see jane foster's thor
and arthor together again along with the
rest of the crew valkyrie and korg on a
boat and thor puts stormbreaker down and
he does this so he can summon the
bifrost and then tooth nasher and tooth
grinder his two mystical goats who can
fly through space take them to olympus
now in this dialogue that happens
between thor and jane foster there's a
little bit of misdirect here thor says i
want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there but
as he says this the trailer shows us
jane foster's thor fighting people at
olympus now this is not what he is
referring to he is not referring to this
battle scene this scene hasn't actually
taken place yet because this is in
olympus and that's where they're going
the impressive part that thor is
referring to is the battle where he
originally sees her and mjolnir where he
reached for mjolnir but it went to jane
foster and we saw those symbiotic type
bad guys in the background now it looks
like jane foster's thor might actually
have a little bit of a different set of
powers than arthor when she's fighting
at olympus it kind of looks like she
uses the hammer to throw ice out she
fires these sort of energy balls out of
the hammer which i do believe are ice
balls because if you listen carefully it
definitely sounds like ice now thor is
the god of thunder so he can use thunder
but perhaps maybe jane has been able to
tap into some other elements as well
which i think would be really cool to
see cinematically thor would be using a
lot of lightning and i'm assuming jane
foster is going to as well but it would
be really cool to see her add some other
elements in there mixing with the
lightning now from here we really see
gore the god butcher's power we see him
take his sword bash it into a planet and
the whole planet gets destroyed now this
could be a planet it might also be a
moon but either way he destroys it which
shows that he has massive power now
towards the end of the trailer here we
see thor jane foster and valkyrie in
what looks to be kind of another
dimension kind of like a little bit of a
negative zone here now i don't actually
think that it's the real negative zone
from the comics i actually think it has
something to do with where null came
from the creator of the symbiotes who i
mentioned before who gore got the
necrosword from in the comics before the
celestials created our universe null
existed in the endless void and he's
also originally from the primordial void
so i'm thinking that this is some type
of void reality where gore can go to and
he can transfer people to as well this
is where i believe they are all fighting
and if i had to assume i would say that
this is a place where gore is probably
much stronger in his own realm and i
actually think that due to the whole you
know sony has the rights to venom and
symbiotes and everything i think that
marvel studios is probably going to
combine knoll and gore the god butcher
into one person kind of like they did
with hella in thor ragnarok now what's
really cool is that gore actually says
to thor you're not like the other gods
that i've killed i'm assuming we'll meet
many gods in this movie and i'm sure
some of them are going to be stuck up
and arrogant and not really care about
anybody else but themselves which is why
gore wants to kill a good majority of
the gods but this shows us that our god
of thunder is different and our thor
says it's because he has something worth
fighting for and as he says this we see
the little pinkies of thor and jane
foster kind of grab onto each other kind
of showing us that they are in love and
they are back together which we love to
see now something that's really really
cool in a blink and you'll miss it
moment is the scene where valkyrie is
fighting gore she is actually using a
lightning bolt to fight against gore and
of course she's going to get this from
zeus whether or not she takes it from
him or he gives it to her it's
definitely from zeus now another blink
and you'll miss it moment is where we
see jane foster's thor hold her hammer
up in the air and summon lightning now
she is in some sort of a chamber and if
you notice to her left and her right we
can see certain statues and some of them
are very very familiar if you look to
the right of her we can actually see the
heads of the living tribunal and we can
also see next to it the head of the
watcher now to the left it looks to be
someone who looks like the grim reaper
however the grim reaper in marvel comics
does not have a skull for a face but
lady death does have a skull for a face
sometimes and that's who this could be
now there are two other statues behind
lady death but they're really really
hard to make out the one in the far back
could be the cosmic entity infinity this
seems to be some sort of a chamber of
very very powerful entities so it would
make sense that infinity would be there
because we see the living tribunal and
the watcher and the one in the middle
kind of looks like it could be destroyed
again we don't get a really clear look
at it but these statues do look like
they're made of gold so this most likely
is on olympus and i'm guessing that zeus
is going to be able to provide some sort
of an insight on other gods to thor now
thor is over a thousand years old so he
probably knows a good amount but not as
much as zeus because remember zeus is
supposed to be god of the gods and i'm
sure thor only knows about zeus through
his father his father's probably
mentioned him at some point in time but
in this final scene here we see thor on
olympus and it doesn't look like it's
going too well for him zeus seems to
have him in chains but it does look like
zeus doesn't know who he is we see for
the first time russell crowe as zeus
surrounded by his ladies beside him who
i'm assuming worship him because he's
the god of gods but we hear him say
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise and he does a little flick and
with that little flick he manages to
flick off all of thor's clothes in which
all of the girls beside him and some men
next to them all faint looking at thor's
body but this also shows you just how
powerful zeus is with the flick of his
fingers he flicks off all of thor's
clothes now we see valkyrie korg and
jane foster on the side and they don't
appear to be chained up they look like
they're guests so perhaps zeus has
something against thor maybe he had
something against odin again it's unsure
because odin says that he's in disguise
so he probably didn't know it was thor
at the time however we do see a scene
where thor is fighting what looks to be
some guards with the chains that he was
held down with and then we see the scene
with jane foster getting into that same
platform using mjolnir to fight some
people as well so i'm assuming it
doesn't go well at first but perhaps
zeus eventually remembers who thor is
and kind of becomes a little bit nicer
and shows them a little bit more
hospitality i'm sure a combination of
thor and jane foster showing zeus their
powers and also telling him that
somebody is going around killing gods
might get his attention and that's it
for the full official trailer for thor
love and thunder where we got our first
look at gore the god butcher be sure to
let me know what you think about this
trailer and how gore looks in the
comments down below and let me know your
favorite part don't forget to like the
video and of course subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof